The 2023 Oscars were filled
with plenty of highs and lows,
including a host who didn't exactly please
everyone. For the 95th Academy Awards,
Jimmy Kimmel was once again tapped as the emcee,
having previously hosted the ceremony in 2017 and
2018. But the third time wasn't exactly the
charm, at least according to some viewers.
Following Kimmel's opening monologue, which
highlighted the night's nominated films,
social media quickly began to blow up
with thoughts about his jokes. Multiple
users thought his delivery timing was
off and that he maybe needed to slow
down a bit. One person even referenced a
certain fictional conductor by tweeting,
"We need Lydia Tár pushing Jimmy Kimmel
off the stage at the Oscars just for fun."
While Kimmel's jokes weren't necessarily that
bad, it's always fun to see viewers come up with
clever references to the nominated films. Kimmel
actually praised Tár, but some observers found his
thoughts on the Cate Blanchett starring vehicle
to be condescending. As one person tweeted,
"Jimmy Kimmel [is] making jokes
about Tár as if the entire scene
he just mocked isn't a biting satire
on everything happening tonight."
Others weren't exactly pleased when Kimmel went
negative. While the Oscars have never shied away
from calling out some of Hollywood's duds and
misfires, some viewers thought that his jab at
the Damien Chazelle-directed Babylon went way
too far. As one person tweeted in all caps,
"GET JIMMY KIMMEL OFF THE STAGE I
DRAW THE LINE AT BABYLON SLANDER."
Another fan of the Oscar-nominated
epic agreed by tweeting,
"[I'm] gonna start the Jimmy Kimmel
hate train for the Babylon diss."
Some viewers even went so far as
to declare that Kimmel's monologue
was a total bomb. As one of them bluntly tweeted,
"How many more years must we
be subjected to Jimmy Kimmel?"
Kimmel was also called out by Indian cinephiles
for referring to the Telugu-language film
RRR as a Bollywood production, when
"Tollywood" would've been more accurate.
"Do you know Desi Naach?"
While Kimmel received his fair share of
flack on the internet, some other viewers
were actually pleased with how the host was
mostly sharing the magic of cinema. He was
praised for eliciting gasps and nervous laughter
from the crowd. At least one Twitter user went
so far as to declare the monologue one of the
best in recent memory. And as another noted,
"Jimmy [Kimmel's] monologue [is] going well, good
job on the no women director [nomination] joke."
Kimmel was also positively compared to past
Oscar hosts like Bob Hope and Johnny Carson.
And he enjoyed a callout to a spectacle
from across the pond, as someone tweeted,
"His parachute in was [a] ripoff of Queen and Bond
at [the] London Olympics [but] a better version."
Though Kimmel's third outing as Oscars host wasn't
able to please everyone, at least he was able to
find some fans on social media. But ultimately in
many ways, it doesn't really matter who the hostis.
After all, viewers across the world are mainly
tuning in to celebrate cinema. And regarding that
requirement, Kimmel did a decent job. His opening
monologue highlighted some of the year's most
inventive films and reminded audiences just how
important seeing movies on the big screen is.
Kimmel even went ahead and casually called out
James Cameron and Tom Cruise for not showing up
to the ceremony, even though they're two of the
theatrical experience's most ardent supporters.
Some Twitter users although that Kimmel
deserves praise for not shying away from
pointing out how no women were
nominated for Best Director thisyear.
And they also found it hard not
to appreciate him for dragging Warner
Bros. Discovery over their cancellation of
the Batgirl movie starring Leslie Grace.
Kimmel wasn't perfect, but he also doesn't
deserve a toxic spew of hatred. Then again,
the jokes pitting him against
Lydia Tár were pretty hilarious.
"Who, may I ask, gets to decide that?"
This year, more than ever, it's
crystal clear that the Oscars
wanted to celebrate the movies. And Jimmy
Kimmel clearly understood the assignment.